la boucle est bouclée pour guillaume
aurélien et martin ses trois amis
d'enfance s'était lancé le défi de faire
un tour de france en tandem triplette un
étrange vélo à trois places fait sur
mesure pour l'occasion parti de saint
cloud le 10 juillet ils sont arrivés le
6 août devant le château de versailles a
pris trois mille kilomètres en 24 étapes
moi je retiens du bonheur parce que
c'était du bonheur aussi un peu de
souffrance on va pas se mentir parce qu
on a fait quand même on attendait quand
même en moyenne à peu près 110 120 km
par jour beaucoup de solidarité et
d'entraidé de la part de entre nous déjà
et c'est important parce que on est tous
passés par des petits coups de mou mais
il y avait deux autres pour nous
soutenir et beaucoup d'entraidé de
solidarité des personnes qui nous ont
accueillis et qu'on a rencontrées tout
au long du tout au long du parcours je
retiendrai la chaleur sur ce tour et
plus sérieusement la diversité des
paysages des gens et l'ouverture
d'esprit des gens qu'on a rencontrés une
idée qui a vu le jour en 2019 le tandem
triplette leur est apparu rapidement
comme une évidence on avait la sensation
qu'ils avaient un tandem triplette salle
est différent dans l'effort on s'est pas
trompé ça je pense un peu rien à voir on
est sur le bateau on est ensemble on
veut pas s'arrêter on a envie d'aider le
copain un des trucs cool avec la
triplette c'est que ça tape tape à
l'oeil entre guillemets donc elle à
micheline comme on l'appelle c'est c'est
son petit prénom elle faisait un peu le
travail pour nous du coup les gens
venaient nous voir donc du coup c'est
une super occasion pour parler du projet
par l'association dormir chez l'habitant
problèmes techniques sur le vélo ou
encore rencontres enrichissantes ils
n'ont pas hésité à partager leur
aventure solidaire au plus grand nombre
sur leur compte instagram
si les trois amis se sont lancés dans ce
périple c'est avant tout au profit de
l'association des enfants et des arbres
objectif récolter des fonds qui
financeront des plantations cet hiver
des enfants les armes c'est une
association qui travaille avec des
agriculteurs et des agricultrices
français pour replanter les arbres dans
nos campagnes et dans leur exploitation
concrètement il met en lien une classe
de collège au primaire avec un
agriculteur qui m'a présenté son projet
de plantation dans la classe et après
c'est les enfants qui viennent
dans son exploitation avec l'agriculteur
lui donner un coup de main pour
replanter des armes avec lui une
collecte de dons qui se fait par le
biais d'une cagnotte en ligne 13 1975
euros ont déjà été récoltés pour le
moment la cagnotte est encore ouverte
pour une dizaine de jours